[Music]
I'm so excited about our next guest he's
the hilarious actor who stars on NBC's
Parks and Recreation please welcome
everybody Adam Scott
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Howie how are you hi Pete I thought is
this work I don't know I'm so afraid
okay this you know this is actually
really comfortable I'm just gonna let
the audience interview if that's okay
some ways what did thank you very much I
did this is this your research team I'm
pulling audience your segment producer
basically oh yeah birthday
I yeah well everyone does yeah are you
seriously touching me right keep your
hands off me you're very good
do that again be mad that I'm touching
your jacket again but be happy yeah yeah
you do to everyone does isn't that funny
bro thank you cuz you used to be a
serious one yeah that's right you mean
like I didn't like a serious I know you
from party down right that's where I
first got introduced here which
obviously your characters a little bit
more serious but in a funny way right
and but before that you were doing some
real you know non comedy stuff yeah I
kind of always thought I would be like
when I started out which was in like
1993 I just I wanted I just thought I
would I was like wanting to be like
Stephen Dorff like God like a serious
act what is Stephen Dorff in how you
don't know Stephen don't embarrass me
okay he's been in lots of movies he was
in the blade he's the bad guy in blade
do you not know what I know you told me
backstage that you don't watch anything
and now you're proving it no no I watch
films blade blade is black vampire or
it's a Wesley Snipes film
oh I'm sorry you found a new way for me
to be raised yes I did
[Applause]
how about a Sidney Poitier vehicle
movies with white vampires were called
Hogan again you could just call that a
Jim Jarmusch movie no it's a lonely
feeling when you open the Jammu store
yeah there's just no one there for you
never again I'm gonna pitch this you we
do a blade reboot yeah your blade call
it Wade okay when do we start
it's the whole because
[Music]
it's great to get applause for something
like
[Music]